Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David P, this caller has a
quite frankly great suggestion about tomorrows
charity membership drive. Take a listen.
Speaker 4: Hello, David. Sir, is Liberty calling
you from Connecticut? I have a question. When you
have the New Meadow Drive and the first month is
going to be you're going to match donations. Yes,
Charity. And I don't know the name, but I
know about the charity. What I would like
to suggest is if you have either a phone or on
on your site, an option for those of us who are
already members. Right. To donate what would
be equivalent to one month's memberships? Yes.
For that same purpose, to be doubled and donated.
Speaker 1: We've got it. Okay. If you were already
a member tomorrow, when we do the end of the
year charity membership drive, you can get as
many memberships as you want for other people
by checking the box that says this is a gift.
The payment will be donated. It will be doubled
and the membership will be given to someone on
our membership waiting list, which you can find
at David Pakman dot com slash free membership.
We're doing all of it. And you can you can quite
literally give the membership to anyone you want.
Speaker 2: Sue Chin, Tendulkar.
Speaker 1: Well, it's better if you know how to
spell the person's name, which I don't know that
Trump did when he started reading those names.
But you can send the membership to anyone you
want, or you can just leave that blank and we'll
give it away. We've got, like, a thousand people
waiting for memberships. Okay, bonus show today.
We're going to talk about Mike Leigh's
new obsession with banning porn.
We're going to talk about the permanent
disappearance of daily room cleanings at
hotels since the pandemic. Good or bad, we'll
talk about it. And we will talk about American's
self-reported mental health at a new low. Not
good, not good. All of those stories and more
on today's bonus show. Sign up at join Pacman dot
com get instant access to the world famous phone.